foreign
in Omaha Nebraska what's up Jen
oh my gosh Dr John I cannot believe I'm
talking to you I you know I was just
thinking I cannot believe I'm talking to
Jen from Omaha
hey what what is like um
uh what's like the
thing to do in Omaha
um well like I know Bright Eyes is from
there like a songwriter that I love but
other than oh that I don't know anything
about Omaha what's like the thing to do
in Omaha
well the College World Series is always
pretty popular yeah it is I need to go
to that that's on my bucket list and
thanks Omaha Steaks are from there
yes awesome they're delicious
they're delicious anyone that doesn't
understand Nebraska it really is
beautiful you just got to get off the
interstate oh it's stunning I've been
there yeah it's these beautiful Hills
that just go on for eternity it's it's
it's it's incredible yeah I love it I
love it all right so what's up how can I
help I want a geography podcast so bad
but they won't let me have one all right
so what's up
so
I
um
I've just been battling with this
question for quite a while and I just
can't seem to find an answer but
my question is how do you find your
identity again after being a cheater
tell me more
so
I don't even know where to start
honestly
um
I've
so my husband and I we've been together
10 years married for four and
um
we always kind of had
little issues in our relationship prior
to being engaged and married and my best
like description of that was the Red
Flags never caused me to raise the White
Flag so we just kind of moved through it
and you know took everything in stride
and
then
um we went through like a really
stressful time in our life we were we
were engaged planning our wedding we
decided to both go back to school
because we wanted to further our careers
that was during covid and
um after we got married I got pregnant
so we were and I was working in
healthcare it was just a whole lot of
stress all in one and when I when we
came out on the other side
I had a different career at a different
place and I got out of Health Care
and I um
met
a guy through my new career and I
connected with him on an emotional level
that out stepped outside the boundaries
of my marriage and you know it's been
about
a year and a half now
and we've
um
we just separated and
you know it's just a lot you and your
husband or you and him okay no um
this me and my husband just separated
okay
um did you sleep with this guy
no okay
so
you met somebody who had a crush on them
after his particularly chaotic time
um
you violated it like you violated your
own conscience here right
there had to be there had to be more of
a reason why y'all separated
um well that was
mostly from things that were going on in
our own relationship but a lot of it
I think he really blames
the cheating but
I have I mean we've we've been in
therapy for like over a year now and
um I've I've even listened to parts of
your podcast that you know kind of give
um direction or maybe some guidance as
to like how we could work through these
things and I feel like we
were
I don't know if I should say we but I
feel like I kind of tried to
reconcile what had gone on and he didn't
want to and he told me that yeah I bowed
out and now he wants to wonder why we're
separating and
that's right so
I just feel like I can't ever
you know like I I held myself to such a
standard in my life that I was a I'm a
good person and I have morals and I have
no I think what you did was I think I
think you tethered your values to a
series of things you won't do
and if we tether our values to a series
of things I don't do I don't drink I
don't smoke I don't have sex I don't
ever
have a crush or fall deeply
um for somebody that I'm not married to
I don't sleep with somebody I'm not
married to what fill in the blank
I don't steal
if you anchor your values into a series
of actions you don't take
and you stumble into or walk into or do
one of those actions your entire
um identity your entire picture of
yourself Burns to the ground
and you so you anchored into not I'm
somebody who is always growing I'm
somebody I want to be the best wife
possible
then you
have an emotional affair with somebody
and you
um
uh
sit down have a hard conversation and
You Weep and you grieve and you mourn
what was and you'll build something new
and then you continue to try to be the
best wife you can be
because you weren't in that moment it
wasn't a or in that season it was not a
uh it's not an a picture that is stamped
into concrete this is who you are
it was a bad bad season but when you
anchor into I will not do this thing and
then you do that thing there's nowhere
to go
and just for what it's worth
working through this I think is
[Music]
um
one thousand percent possible
you nailed it and I think that's what
you're struggling with he doesn't want
to
I think it was a lot of the other stuff
that went on in our relationship that
I I just
I just could not get my like I could not
wrap my head around doing those things
or being that person tell me about it
which ones tell me let's don't be vague
let's be real Direct
hold on hold on for somebody to call
like the way you ask the question let's
just start here and just get all the
cards out on the table face up like how
do I how do I find my identity after
being a cheater
the way you asked that I thought you
were going to tell me that you cheated
on a high school boyfriend you cheated
on three College boyfriends and you
slept with three or four guys since
you've been married
this is if I'm not wrong
you met somebody you fell for them you
probably had some conversations you
shouldn't have had you were hiding your
cell phone from them maybe sent pictures
you shouldn't have like
tell me tell me what I'm missing here
because you're you're you're the label
and identity you've given to yourself is
not what I would have given you
hit the nail on the head
I just don't
see if my husband don't work things out
which honestly I I the way that things
are going I don't see us getting back
together but partially with the
separation was for us to
to step back from the relationship that
we've been in and the problems we've
been having and and all of this and to
decide
is is
moving forward together something that
we want to do and we want to work on or
are we going to move forward apart and
you know pull on divorce and
separate everything and
I think um
it's it's it's only been a month that
we've been separated and you know the
other day he he was like I don't want to
drag this out anymore and I was like
it's been four weeks what are we
dragging out like
he may have been divorced for a year
he just didn't have the courage to say
it
because he didn't want to see himself as
a guy who got who his wife had a crush
on somebody else
what else happened at home
so I think the
big
turning point was
um
like about two and a half years ago
when
I think like there's never been much of
like me wanting to do things with him
like physically and his
he is such a physical connector that
you know for for years I just would
kind of push under the rug and and I
would just think that I thought
something was wrong with me that I
didn't feel like I wanted to have sex
with him or like do things with him and
I mean I asked like my doctor and I
tried downloading apps and I tried it to
like make myself want it and I just
didn't and and don't and I think the big
Turning Point a few years ago was
um we got into an argument and
our relationship had always been pretty
good I actually always thought that we
had a stellar relationship above a lot
of other people and
I think I hung on to that Vision until
we got in this argument about I don't
remember what it started with but he
said that he was unwanted and unloved
and
he said
is
like just says life wasn't worth living
anymore and he left
and he told me
not coming back
and I just
could not bear the thought that my child
would lose her father
and
I just I called him and I I tried to
talk him back and and
can I hop in here real quick yeah that
answer you just gave is very instructive
for me
and maybe it's not the full picture I
don't want to hold you to it
but if your husband looks at you and
said I've felt unloved
for long enough
and your first thought is I don't want
to lose my best friend I Don't Want to
Lose the person who I love more than
anything on the planet
this search for me figuring out ways
that I can love you in the ways that you
need to be loved or you want to be loved
will never cease because I love you to
the end of the Moon and back
that's one thing
but your first thought went to I don't
want my daughter to lose her dad
it gets worse okay keep going
I talked him back
and he came back home and
said I mean he I had never seen him in
the state I mean at this point we'd been
together for like eight years and this
is the first time I'd ever seen him cry
and it was just a manic date that I
didn't know what to do and when he came
back home he said you need to give me
physical affection and I said
I want to and I try but I just I just
don't feel it and and he's like well
then I'm just gonna leave again and I'm
I'm not coming back and so I
like
I just made myself
do what he wanted and
you know after it was done
he just
oh he didn't seem to to care that
he essentially was like
making me do something that I didn't
want to do after he just told me
that he's gonna leave and go kill
himself and
the that behavior didn't change
for
about two years
so every time we would get in some sort
of argument or something would happen he
would storm off and leave and threaten
things and if I didn't
bow down to the physical
intimacy then
um
I just I just could not but hold on
you're describing two different things
there's a difference between a sexless
marriage there's difference between what
is so gross about me that you won't hold
my hand you won't put your hand on my
shoulder those are super common
conversations that anybody who works
with couples has on a daily basis
what you're describing is abuse
you will do this particular sex act with
me or I'm going to kill myself
well that's like how the cycle went for
so long I know but listen to me listen
to me that is not love and affection
that is abuse that is taking advantage
of somebody
that is not what that is
and you can be very loving and very
affectionate
and say one this sex act isn't for me
I'm not into it
and of all my like what I would call my
ride or dies like my long-term friends
and family every one of those couples
and we're super close but we've been
close since we were back in college
um sometimes in high school
everyone's everyone's like I'm not into
that I'm super into that it's all
different it's all different
but it's it's a conversation between a
couple right so hear me say you're not
crazy it's just boiled down to I
couldn't say no
hold on you could well I don't say I I
being in those kind of situations is is
a mess and that's not for me to judge
from here
um
so on let's back all the way out and get
back to your original question because
let me say this
your
um I think this relationship needs
infinitely more work than you think it
does
oh yeah okay
and if you were to call me and just have
told me what you said without you like
having a crush on this on a co-worker if
what you had just if you just called and
said my husband says either I do this
particular sex act or he says he's going
to kill himself in storms out of the
house I would tell you to run
and if you've listened to this show very
long you know I don't tell people that
but that's a that's a
manipulative degrading way to
get what you want
it has no place inside of a marriage
I think where
where despite everything that went on
and I still did that I just feel like I
can't trust myself like am I even worthy
of being committed to to another person
absolutely ever again in my life like
can I call myself a good person yes ever
again in my life I will I'll call you
good person right now
I just don't feel like as someone who
did that like I just can't
I just I just don't feel like I am like
worthy of being in a relationship
or worthy of being considered a good
person who has any sort of moral or
value in their life I think you anchored
into
good people do this and good people
don't do that
good people stay married forever
good wives make their husbands
um so happy they just can't leave
anywhere else
bad wives husbands leave them bad wives
do X Y or Z bad wife say no this hurts
bad wives say this makes me feel
uncomfortable so I'm not gonna do any of
that
which what you're saying is good wives
bury themselves in the yard
and become walkways for their husbands
bad wives say no have boundaries Etc
did you do something that was dumb yeah
100 percent
or I'll even I'll even back out of that
did you do something that violated one
of your core values yeah he did
you got to make peace with yourself yeah
in the future
if you're with somebody and you're in a
committed relationship and somebody at
work is hilarious or good looking or
they make you feel alive or they put
their hand in the smaller back and let
tell you to go out of the elevator first
and it just sends a jolt of electricity
through does that happen yeah
and now you know I'm not going to
respond to those tags
or I just don't respond to texts
or I don't I'm not gonna answer those
emails or fill in the blank you see what
I'm saying like you've learned
to not go down those roads anymore
yeah the ultimate question is
is Jen going to be able to get to a
place where Jen honors and loves Jen
again
and what I want to tell you is
sounds like for the last few years and
let's like there's no way this just
popped up after eight years
there has been some sort of they call it
in the the one down position so it like
in counseling there's the one-up
position there's the guys that beat
their chest and scream and yellow are
the wives who scream and yell and beat
their chest whatever then there's the
one down position usually it's well you
guys just go eat whatever you want I'll
just be hungry that's fine and
everyone's like all right well where do
you want to go eat right so it's a very
like okay well just whatever I'll just
I'll just sleep on the couch then if if
you need those sheets on the bed it's
that right that's that's a power move I
would be willing to bet money that that
has been part of The Narrative of your
marriage that just erupted into a
you do this or I'm killing myself
and so often when somebody's been in a
relationship for so long that's full of
chaos that's full of uh ups and downs
and is being dragged around underwater
by someone who's manipulative
to the point of the abuse you've
suffered you you get disconnected from
yourself
and you try to find reasons to justify
why this insane evil behavior is
happening to you
and then I have a conversation like this
that breaks my heart
because sometimes it's
well did you gain 10 pounds yes are you
the grossest no stop
did this happen yes did you forget his
keys yes
did you fall for somebody at work and
not sleep with them yes that happened
but for some reason you've bought into
that narrative that you're the worst
person who's ever lived actually did you
hear me say you're not
I personally think the separation is
really good
and after four weeks if he wants to bail
then I think
um his behavior is a language and he's
giving you all the information you need
and you're gonna have to grieve the loss
of your marriage
but this marriage is not going to end
because
you had a crush on a co-worker period
do you believe me when I say that
I feel like it's something that
I want to believe but it's it's so hard
to I know
it's the truth
my
if you haven't already I think it's
important for you to get with a
counselor on your own and I want you to
speak out loud exactly what you've told
me
and my guess is you have not told that
story
especially not to a mental health
professional because every alarm they
have would have gone off like mine is
right now
I'm so so so so so sorry
but no
you're not a terrible person yes you're
worthy of being loved yes you're worthy
of being loved forever
yes this is your relationship
um may not stand this test it's over
maybe not but it sounds like it and if
you don't choose to stay together
there's gonna have to be some
drastic changes in both you and
especially your husband's way of
interacting with the world
and he's gonna have to take a knee in
front of his wife and say I've abused
you for years and that stops now
you're worth more than this gin